wir sind ja irgendwo auf der welt
rausgekommen ihr fällt dann runter
mach mal kurz mit rechts komponiert hat
wir sind mit laufen wer einfach mal
wollten einfach ihrem ein hühnerstall
obsidian wie viele brauchen wir acht
nehmen 1 224 und dann haben wir mit 19
10 alter ich habe acht ich glaube ich
hatte meiner kiste auch noch was wenn
ich jetzt mal ganz kurz überlege ich
hab' ich habe auch noch was viel in der
mob falle aber da komme ich nicht gut
ran de das portal bei team besteht aus
wieviel blöcken was ich ja 16 obsidian
läuft ostportal vorjahr zurück wir
brauchen ein zwei drei vier jahren
wirklich 10
und wir bezahlt haben wir zu dir
mit seinem ja der ist und einfach so
planmäßig im dorf nachgebaut der
lulatsch bürgermeister bürgermeister
worüber ich weiß ja ich muss meinen
links suchen ein feuerzeug kogler ich
mein die luft wenn du meinen namen
gesehen hast du mal rüber gleich moment
ich muss den sekt wieder mit feuerzeug
machen menschen sind es blöcke 60
abdruck tools für mich und es ist auf
tims grundstücke auf dem weg in münchen
rausgekommen
du hast echt so bekomme ich habe
gelitten sagte eyermann dass jetzt die
komplette erste juristische gute
erfahrungen ja ich bin letztens übrigens
wieder gestorben
in halle habe ich habe drei mäntel
deswegen kann man bauen wir wollen nicht
nur über ein problem der jetpack das ist
doch nicht so schnell mal wieder
aufgenommen ich habe solar in der ich
nicht
dann können wir den tauschen außerdem
gehen wir nur geradeaus eigentlich ne yo
hoffe doch mal wie schnell das geht
nicht diamond drill total schnell jung
das ist krass schnell
wir wollen aber um die 5000 blöcke weg
hier ist mein blickpunkt im blickpunkt
ich hätte meine diamond verzaubern
sollen jetzt geht ja nicht mehr so
schnell vergisst man in diamant
spitzhacke wie weit müssen wir weg keine
ahnung also momentan momentan sind wir
gerade mal 35 blöcke weit weg
hätte ich mal backpack mitgenommen was
oder mining laser oder ein keine ahnung
die kommen dann ins tor ansonsten dass
du mal jetzt hast du mal deine geräte
hier
ich habe mich fast kaputt so spitzer
gerettet ich bin sogar mehr aufgerüstet
besser als du alter ich habe einfach
nicht die wollen wir zurückgehen und ein
bisschen planen und aber mehrfach jetzt
schon nicht portal gehen und endlich
lage heute auf das dauert mindestens
stunde erfreuliche laden jetzt die
sachen aufnahme wieder zurück die
knollen dann gehen wir mal eben
pausenglocke weit weg aber schnell eine
meinung leichter geht das die welt
schnell
dabei wirst bohlens hallo es dort
insgesamt stunde kann eine halbe stunde
auf leben
wieso kannst einheimischen auf dem du
penner ich möchte nur eine halbe stunde
aufnehmen kann
das denkt und ich muss oft viel
bearbeiten noch viel von morgen
vorbereiten und da kann ich nicht länger
heute läuft auf jeden fall wird bei dir
auf mensch ich brauche ich uns ja schon
mal vorbereiten
eine möglichkeit habe ich nicht nach
saerbeck oder so was ich mit energie
backpack was ist denn ein leppek einlädt
backpacker ich glaube damit kann man
energie speichern
er war es das andere ja doch chillig
damit kann man energie speichern
jawohl ich hab mal was richtiges gesagt
ja man entladen sich damit jetzt die
sachen auf ja wenn du das teilen wieder
auflebt dann schon natürlich dass
300.000 eu drin
naja dann das los gehen alter daimler
läuft zum teil habe ich sekunde aber
erstmal wieder jetpack aufsetzen so was
soll ich denn noch mitnehmen
auch energie sachen halt habe ich nicht
viele dann deimel
diamond habe ich auch nicht die luft
gejagt von den herzlich wenig ja ich
folge dir einfach kommen einfach
ich bin schon wieder im gange war ich
bin schon wieder auf dem grundstück und
ich sprinte und der holzmichel lebt noch
und ich bin gleich wieder so ich bin wir
in der hölle und lädt sich moskau nicht
nee ich hab das leppek auf aber es legt
sich nicht auf
sie waren das ich hab das schon mal bei
der wm gesehen glaube ich die wahlen
dass ich weiß wie wir es ging glaube ich
du musst das teil was du aufladen möchte
ist komplett aufbrauchen
dann lädt sich das auch okay meine aber
der diamond trade bleibt jetzt immer mal
10.000 die eu will ich das map pack
darunter ok wir können theoretisch
unendlich weit reisen bis zu hinter mir
von der decke tropft soll mutter gesagt
mensch wieder hallte das ist ihr gleich
irgendwo in lava fall so wichtig weil
ich auch alles genau wird man gucken
kann dir wie du einfach durch so ein
loch durch fels nach unten weg durch
aber ganz schön meinen jetpack was ich
gerade nicht mehr auf habe scheiße du
krebs gleich erstmal wissen weiter
wechseln uns jetzt gleich ab genau in 30
sekunden
natürlich da jetzt genau die gleiche
strecke wie wir gehen soll eigentlich
nur wegen dir los wegen wie halt dein
maul jetzt mit der junge alter ich
sterbe kommen ich sterbe ich
läufer nicht fleisch danke ich bin aber
vegetarier die du willst es weiter hier
guck was ich mache du musst dich mach
mir ein gefühl das ist ein spiel in
portugal dabei wäre ich die verlierer
haben
randy quaid trade matching drauf machte
er am ende wiesen tischen am ende der
guckt ihr erst mal einer was weiter
gewaltig alter oft nicht weit fliegen
ich habe mein gepäck nicht auf junge
[ __ ] ich da ja nicht jetzt in lava
gefallen dabei wie marvel oder ohne weil
das könnte ich dann verzaubern oder hast
du es als stein ja und gib mir mal bitte
gib mir mal bitte also dann verwandelt
da hole ich würd ich auch noch mal ein
bisschen so viel du kannst genau
danke danke bester mann ist so
machen sie bitte aus dem zauberstab okay
da habe ich ja von stevan denke aber
kann ich das auch machen wenn ich noch
welche pause mache ich dir da ein mit
mache ich viel alter richtig fürs handy
weil ich den prof
wenn du auch mal mit zaubern anfängst
dann kannst du den dafür gebraucht für
schuldig ja aber wie ich will jetzt
weiter komme er kannst dich mal
weitergehen ich folge dir gleich ok ich
glaube ihnen die richtung gleich fragt
sich ja wieder
ich warte auf dich jung lossau normal so
mega fit ich habe eine festung gefunden
eine festung geil places stimmt man
findet ihr eine hölle places stimmt
alter junge das war voll die gute idee
von mir jetzt aber auch schon alles
zugebaut mit mabel und wir denken hier
wissen voll weit weg bevölkerung
das ist mein stolzen kloster träumen
weiter
ich bin mein glas ton komme erst konnte
mir hier meine meinung und jahren rex
doch gerne haben wechselt auch julia
meter schlank schau dir hier unten liegt
denkt aus ton aber ich den geworfen zwei
stück weit danke im letzten match etwas
abhilfe kann hier hoch geflogen
ich bin hier links oben sie ist mein
name hier bin ich das sonst lässt ich
sage das ist mein kopf an der einen kopf
drop hat keine dropped okay ich habe ihn
noch zwei köpfe
wo wollen wir einfach mal auch wieder
witherspoon und ja ich habe das einmal
angespannt das erstmal weiter laufen so
ein bisschen you
wir nehmen ihn erstmal mit ok das heißt
wir müssen jetzt normal ich unbedingt
leises ja ich brauche auch places komme
wofür brauchst du bleiben oder wollen
wir was zusammen machen mit places das
jetzt beide benutzen können nein ich
brauche das für die mob falle von lets
gameplay und mir tut mir leid ich
brauche junge ist es meiner jugend ich
habe ihnen gefunden
er trennt sich unsere wege ins dorf
besuchte eine andere folge selber weiter
weil ich brauch wie gesagt aber ich weiß
nicht genau wofür du dir aber ich habe
die erfahrung und ob alle lampen laces
erfahrung her klar übel sind die mobs
mit der meisten erfahrung springs pumps
dass überhaupt eine rolle die es nie
aber ich will ich das ist halt die
voraussetzung für den notfall ist max
born und jetzt habe ich ihn dann nimm
das ding meinetwegen
da kannst du dann eben kurz hier im
portal baumann suchen wir für dich
gleich auch noch mal an hunger juni ich
habe diese festung gefunden ich hab den
leo gerät einfach hinterher gelaufen nur
weil du etwas gefunden hatte
dollar auf dem weg sagt jammer erwartet
schildower kostet fahrzeug brauche ich
warte hier brauchen großfeuer das feuer
ich habe dich mit einer jungen wir
finden heute für dich noch ein
blaze brauchst du acht stück jungen
agenten erregt man ja auch wegen ein
hallo
so kommen überhaupt mitnehmen so die ihk
geht also sollte gehen ich hoffe ich
doch einfach mal jetzt auf einmal bleibt
der seine dimensionen stecken
wir sind ja irgendwo auf der welt
rausgekommen
ihr fällt sand runter mach mal kurz mit
rechts ein kombinierter wir sind mit
laufen mehr junge läuft einfach mal sie
auf die haut
wir sind mitten hoffen mit er nicht mehr
fortsetzen so ein traum ein traum
entdecken die höhle ja wir ertrinken
noch keine witze kommt mehr rein leben
wie weit sind wir gospel weg mache jetzt
meine rechtsportal nach hause
als ich mir wieder in den anderen soll
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt schon
kommen konnte contra bist du bleibst du
andere ich bin durch natürlich stellen
wir hier ins haus
nein ok dann behalten
er behalte deine blöden sporty raus du
musst einfach mal zu ende bauen
hamburg spaß also das dach ist eine
sache das ist noch eine schwierige
geschichte weil ich mich dann einigen
vertan habe komme kann ich mich mal
zählen ja das ist einmal der punkt und
auf anderen seite bin ich mir nicht ganz
sicher wie ich damit weitermachen möchte
aber es kommt auch noch etwas für meine
folge wäre dass an der stelle ich weiß
nicht wie es bei dir ist erstmal hier
wäre ich wird dann auch eine halbe
stelle und wollen wir nicht dann noch
irgendwie jetzt ganz kurzen leide ich
kann heute kommt es also an der stelle
gebärden okay leute dann wenn es euch
gefallen hat dürfte gerne bewährten
wirklich bedürftigen kommentieren und
wenn es euch gefallen hat mir sehr
gefallen hat dann dürft ihr gerne
bewährt sind das video auf facebook und
twitter und instagram und ask m und der
ganz anderen art teilen
und wenn es euch gefallen hat schlag den
ball mit einer spitzhacke direkt auf die
fresse oder dem contractor ja und dann
würden würde ich was ich muss ja immer
was zeigen wir hier kurz mit in mein
haus plötzlich als verteidigen kannst
auch so was ich muss ja mal kurz was
sein hund mitkommen
overton wie perfekt
hatte ich möchte ich nicht einmal was
fragen sie mich an und von technik so
bisschen danach können wir nicht ich bin
ja natürlich ich so ein fall
guck mal bitte einmal in meiner bar mit
der transportiert ist keine gute idee
ich bei dir auch so da der bildschirm
somit zur roten lettern wenn du jetzt
auf ratings indigenous blablabla da
unten links richtig machst du bist ja
gut leute
naja haut rein und höfen wollen einfach
einen schalter hat sich selber getroffen
wie mein base was ich sehe kein blaze
hier hier vorn sind 80
die dürften nichts bonn
einer sowie der nachbarschaft auf jeden
fall über viel laune junge hör mal wer
da herr reiter und einer stelle schill
noch kurz ich mache noch kurz weiter
wie support ich hab das perfekt
ausgeleuchtet mehr geht man nicht
ausleuchten kann man nicht nein
entweder über les bains sitz dollar oder
oder du bist hier mit ein paar places
rechnen
ich brauche das einfach ein ins bonner
das ja nichts bauen kann
nokia macht das ja gut leute haut da
rein für meine folge uns schön mit der
schau an alle leute davon gekommen ich
wollte noch eben ein und einfach weil
ich kann hier mit
mit sandy bridge wenn es reicht wenn das
geht überhaupt damit keine ahnung
das wette ich meine die idee kam mir von
dir dass keine wirklich klar
naja ich habe den plan alter so ich
glaube ihr müsst wissen gomez total
krank
ja es geht schon wieder gestern war ich
total krank mittlerweile geht es wieder
bergauf
der kauf sogar bei der tour de france
produkts produkts ist richtig so wartet
ja du bleibt es aber noch so lange meine
aufnahmen schillig stunde vielleicht
eine halbe stunde oder so eine gute
nachricht
hey was geht ab bei dir in deinen firma
von fricks lp aus dem urlaub so dass
teure folgen die sind zum urlaub
schreiben sie gar zeit mit uns hat wenn
die gar nicht im urlaub eigentlich
wieder ich glaube am ersten viertel oder
ersten vier diesen vierten leute die
sind richtig langen weg auf jeden fall
ein ganzes jahr
so führt ja vorproduziert stellte erst
mal vor der junge aber die haben schon
heftig vorproduziert all das ist echt
gut gegensatz mehr können sie das wenn
wir was einfach den druckdaten video als
symbol auf dem desktop sortiere ich das
doch eben hier die eier die schmeißt ihn
zum kommen da hinten rüber so duncan das
portfolio der zauberstab hier der
diamond race roten blazer chili red box
leppek santa cruz studie klaus dann das
kommt auch hier ein netter ray kommt
hier
und dann haben wir es auch eigentlich
schon leute ich sortierte haben ja heute
mehr so einkommen von crafter tafel oder
kongresstag am mittag bei unseren beiden
kanälen zwei videos an einem tag so
heute ja du redest grad vom zweiten 90
minuten komme ach ja und zwar montags
meiner einmal und dann gefällt euch das
ich habe ja schon mal gesagt bei mir
welchen die kommentare geschrieben dass
wir das dann nicht immer so etliche job
in bekommen von crafter sondern konnte
hd also cnn e hdi das hd und das konto
so komme hd und das einfach zu connor
hdw konso das wertvolle nahmen alle
nicht so haye nach harmonie im gombe
reden der kriegt doch überdrehen in den
augen wenn der name geändert wird
und ja da floss mit trainer aus meinem
arschloch als dies gehört hat ja ja ja
ich esse jetzt noch kurz was in amerika
titel warum bin ich immer noch im
augenblick lese jetzt einfach drauf und
ihr ein paar kommentare verfasst ich
habe drei blaze peinerin stehender 316
bonner einen schweinsbraten playsport
was bond in dem gebäude nun ein hut ein
gott ist da drin
nächste folge setzt mit anderen mfs tue
ihr habt mir zwei brangelinas soja viele
hatten auch noch geschrieben dass wir
beide auf jeden fall mal mit anderen
zusammen cops and robbers spielen sollen
januar hatten wir gefragt schreibt
einfach mal die kommentare wir das
machen sollen beziehen es nicht den
daumen nach oben
ich würde das so lustig drücken auf den
putsch link bei skype
das ist das aktuelle oberste kommentar
bei ihr kein top kommentar war so ein
kommentar von vor neun minuten sex com
ist so ein behindertes hundeteams
christoph krieger ihre leute bei ihm ist
also denke ich aber auch alter der krieg
erst mal daumen hoch lenken nein also
trotzdem robbers schreibt jetzt einfach
die kommentare für das machen sollen
eventuell nicht kopflos sondern ihnen
der anderem es gibt auch glaube ich es
ist eine map es gibt doch so eine porno
map es gibt ja ganz verschiedene sachen
schreibt in die kommentare was ihr wollt
und dann werden wir uns darum bemühen
hat während machen richtig wichtig
könnte uns auch im team auswählen
mitnehmen dass eventuell machen sollen
weiß nicht freaks und sponsoren damit
einen drauf aber eventuell auch noch
anderes revier zum beispiel nicht da
aber gar nicht endlich mal wie gesagt
wenn ihr das wollt dann schreibt einfach
in die comments und wir sehen uns denn
das nächste mal wieder wer eigentlich
nichts geschafft außer dass ich mir
playsport in 40 wir haben offene fragen
geklärt
da komme wie entstehen die kinder auf
ihre fragen
das klären wir in der nächsten folge von
gomez und gomez jedoch gewiss und conny
scott gomez schritt ich lasse es sein
job bis zum nächsten